welcome back everyone this is the fifth
and final screencast in our series on
analysis methods for NLP I'm going to
seize this moment to tell you about a
brand new method we've been developing
distributed alignment search I think
this overcomes crucial limitations with
causal abstraction as I presented it to
you before so I'm going to give you a
high level overview of Das and then use
that as a starting point to think even
further into the future about analysis
methods in the field
to start let's return to our scorecard
I've been using this throughout the unit
I feel I have Justified the three
Smileys along the interventions row but
there remain really pressing issues for
this class of methods let me Identify
two of them first alignment search is
expensive you know the name of the game
here is to define a high level causal
model and then align variables in that
model with sets of neurons in the Target
neural model
for a complex causal model and a modern
large language model the number of
possible alignments in that mode is
enormous I mean to call it astronomical
would be to fail to do justice to just
how large this space is
as a result we introduced lots of
approximations and we could easily miss
a really good alignment
the second issue is even deeper causal
abstraction could fail to find genuine
causal structure because we presume that
we're doing it in a standard basis and
the central Insight behind Das is that
there might be interpretable structure
that we would find if we simply rotated
some of these representations in various
ways and in fact the target of Das is a
rotation Matrix that we learn and that
helps us find Optimal alignments
I'm going to keep this high level and
intuitive and for that I'll have a
running example a very simple one this
is Boolean conjunction I have the causal
model on the left here it takes in
Boolean variables it has intermediate
variables for those inputs and then it
outputs true if both of the inputs were
true otherwise false
on the right I have a very simple neural
model
and the neural model perfectly solves
our Boolean conjunction task with this
set of parameters
so that's the starting point
now in the classical causal abstraction
mode I could Define an alignment like
this with these red arrows and it looks
good I align the inputs as you would
expect I align the outputs as you would
expect and I'll add in the decision
procedure that if the neural network
outputs a negative value that's false
for the causal model and if it outputs a
positive value that's true for the
causal model so that's intuitive and
then I did the intuitive thing of
aligning V1 with H1 and V2 with H2
now this model is perfect behaviorally
as I said but it does not abstract the
neural model under our chosen alignment
and that chosen alignment bit is crucial
and I'll just give you the spoiler here
what I did inadvertently is reverse the
order of those internal variables I
should have mapped V1 to H2 and V2 to H1
what we're doing with this simple
example is simulating the situation in
which I just made a mistake about what
set of alignments I decided to look at
and I picked one that is sub-optimal in
terms of finding structure that is
actually there
and the promise of Das is that even if I
start with this incorrect alignment a
rotation will help me find it
first I'll just substantiate for you
that we do indeed have a failure of
causal abstraction I'll show you a
failed interchange intervention on the
top as usual we do an intervention with
our causal model we take V1 from the
right example and put it into the
corresponding place in the left example
the original output for the left example
is false but because of the intervention
we should get the output value true
when we do the corresponding aligned
intervention on the neural model
we end up with an output state that is
negative that means predicting false but
the causal model said we should predict
true and that's exactly the kind of
thing that leads us to say that this is
not in the abstraction relationship this
causal model and this neural one
the two models have unequal
counterfactual predictions that is the
heart of it but remember we already know
why they do it's because I chose the
wrong alignment due to bad luck or
resource shortages or whatever
here's the crucial Insight behind Das
the alignment relationship does hold in
a non-standard basis if I take the
current Network and the current
alignment and I simply rotate H1 and H2
using this rotation Matrix then I have a
network that is behaviorally perfect and
satisfies the causal abstraction
relationship right causal abstraction
classical mode missed this because of
the standard basis we chose and the
essence of that is that there was no
reason to choose the standard basis it's
intuitive for us as humans but there's
no reason to presume that our neural
models prefer to operate in that basis
and this example reveals that we might
find interpretable structure by dropping
that assumption about the basis
so the essence of Das to keep an eye on
the ball here is really learning this
rotation Matrix that is the target of of
learning in Das and then the rotation
Matrix becomes the asset that you can
use for actually finding and displaying
and assessing internal causal structure
here's a more high level abstract
overview of how this might happen using
a pair of aligned interventions so I
have my target model in red here
I have two Source models on the left and
right they process their various
examples and we're going to Target the
variables X1 X2 and X3 across these
different uses of the model
the first thing we do
is rotate that representation that we
targeted to create some new variables y1
Y2 and Y3 and remember R here is the
essence of Das and that is the Matrix
that we're going to learn using
essentially interchange intervention
training
having done this rotation I then create
a new Matrix that comes from me deciding
to do an intervention with y1 with Y2
and then copying Y3 over from this core
base example that gives me this new
Vector here and then we unrotate
and we do the intervention
and remember the essence of Das is that
we're going to freeze the model
parameters this is an analysis method
not a method where we change the core
underlying Target Model but the thing
that we do is learn a rotation Matrix
that essentially maximizes The
Interchange intervention accuracy that
we get from doing this rotation and then
on rotation to create these new models
so this is a blend of IIT like
techniques as well as classical causal
abstraction we keep the model Frozen
because we want to interpret it but we
learn that rotation Matrix that's the
essence of Das
findings of Das so far these are pretty
nuanced in our Das paper we show that
models learn truly hierarchical
solutions to a hierarchical equality
task this is in fact the one that's
reviewed in our notebook for this course
but those Solutions are easy to miss
with standard causal abstraction because
of this non-standard basis issue
here's a more nuanced finding
in earlier causal abstraction work we
found that models learn theories of
lexical entailment and negation that
kind of align with a high level
intuitive causal model but with Das we
can uncover that they do that in a kind
of brittle way that actually preserves
the identities of the lexical items
rather than truly learning a general
solution to the entailment issue
and the third finding is from a separate
paper and this is tremendously exciting
because it shows that we can scale to
levels that were impossible before due
to our lack of a need for searching for
alignments because now we essentially
learn the alignment so we scale Das to
alpaca and we discovered that alpaca a 7
billion parameter model implements an
intuitive algorithm to solve a numerical
reasoning task
and I think this is just the start of
the potential that we see for using dis
to understand our biggest and most
performant and most interesting large
language models
all right let me turn now to wrapping up
just some high level conclusions here
first I wanted to return to this diagram
that I used to motivate analysis methods
in general we have these incredibly
important goals for the field
identifying approved and disapproved
uses identifying and correcting
pernicious social biases and
guaranteeing models as safe in certain
contexts
I feel that we cannot offer guarantees
about these issues unless we have
analytic guarantees about the underlying
models and for me that implies a truly
deep causal understanding of the
mechanisms that shape their input output
behavior and for that reason I think the
analysis project in NLP is one of the
most pressing projects for the field
and in that Spirit let's look ahead a
little bit to the near future of
explainability research for the field
first as I said we should be seeking
causal explanations but we also need
human interpretable ones if causality
were the only requirement we could just
give low-level mechanistic mathematical
explanations of how the Transformer
worked and call that explainability
research but that's at the wrong level
for humans trying to offer guarantees
about safety and trustworthiness we need
human interpretable explanations
we need to apply these methods to ever
larger instruct trained llms those are
the most relevant artifacts for the
current moment and I think we're
starting to approach this goal with Das
I just mentioned how we can apply it to
alpaca I think we could scale even
further but we really want to be
unconstrained in terms of what we can
explore and that requires a lot more
innovation in the space
and then finally to kind of return to
the previous unit and our discussion of
cogs and recogs and compositionality
I think we're seeing increasing evidence
that models are inducing a semantics
that is a mapping from language into a
network of Concepts if they are doing
that and if we can find strong evidence
for that it's tremendously eye-opening
about what kinds of data-driven learning
processes could lead a language
technology to actually have induced the
semantics from its experiences which
would in turn lead us down the road of
having many more guarantees that their
behavior would be systematic which could
be a basis for them being again
trustworthy safe and secure and all of
those important goals for the field and
for society